we make way for our next guests and the
official introduction our following
guests fulfilled the dream of every
little boy in Ohio winning a national
title for LSU
he threw 60 touchdowns this season 60
usually we try to do something negative
in these intros and keep our guests
humble but I'm having a hard time doing
that
he was just okay in the game against
Auburn I guess we'll go with that please
welcome our next guest Joe burrow
[Applause]
[Music]
good to meet you
good to meet you oh well yeah you have
Russell Wilson who just walked off stage
and we're yeah I know I hadn't met him
before right not now then all of a
sudden you're trading numbers yeah how
awesome how is awesome how would you sum
up what's happened in the last year for
you it's hard to it's a there's a long
road from where everyone's talking about
me last June to right now so there's
been crazy but explain what happened at
Ohio State that puts you in that
position so those that don't know that
story what happened at Ohio State yeah
so JT Barrett for your starter there I
went in knowing I was gonna be a backup
for for two to three years depending on
if JT left early and then Dewayne came
in Dwayne Haskins and you know we were
battling for two years and then JT's
last year me and Dwayne were battling
for the backup job and before the
decision was made I broke my my throwing
hand so I kind of set me back a little
bit couldn't really throw the way I
wanted to all year and then you know we
had the battle after JT left and in
spring ball and he ended up winning out
and then you just said to your dad
and I graduated in three years and so I
I could go and play immediately did LSU
find you or did you find LSU you know it
was I think they found me coach Bill
Bush was that was that Ohio State with
me for a year and he became the Safety's
coach at LSU and he you know stood on
the table for me with Coach always like
if we get this guy we're gonna win the
national championship he said that to
Mays ago and so he kind of thrown the
table and then they started watching
filling me fell in love with me and I
went on a vision I fell in love with
them okay wait so they he said if we
bring in Joe we're gonna win the
National inside yeah did you know that
he said that to Coach oh I did yeah
that's a little bit of pressure there
Joe not I mean maybe a little but you
know that's what I wanted to do so
that's when he said that to me I got
fired up I was like yeah let's do it
I don't know where your confidence comes
from because it feels like there's just
it's like cocky but it's confident yeah
it comes from preparation you know I
went I win the games on Monday Tuesday
Wednesday
Thursday I don't win them on Saturday so
I'm I'm confident because I understand
what the defense is doing before they do
it and that's that's where my confidence
comes from on Saturdays where'd you
learn that
JT yeah that's that's how I learned you
know I watched film throughout all high
school and all that like like
quarterbacks do my dad taught me a
little bit about it but you know I
really learned how to prepare like a pro
from JT you have any doubts any doubts
about myself
yeah no nothing no why would I well
you're going into the NFL yeah and it's
gonna be very very difficult but I'm
confident that I'm gonna work just about
as hard if not harder than everybody
else and you know if I'm I might be a
good player I might not be a good player
but I know I'm gonna work my hardest to
be the best player I could be were you a
Browns fan growing up so I was so my dad
being a coach I moved around a lot when
I was really young and then I moved to
Ohio and Reggie Bush got drafted to the
Saints and and Drew Brees is with the
Saints and so because of those two guys
like I was kind of a Saints fan growing
up a little bit and kind of transitioned
to a Browns fan later in my high school
career did you meet drew Brees yet I did
yeah that was awesome yeah I tried to
keep it together as we were talking and
I just talked ball and I was standing
there like all that good stuff and
Drew's been a friend of the show for for
a long time and and we had him read his
draft profile so we found all these
negative things that were said prior to
going into the NFL he was so mad and he
said can I keep the key can I keep this
piece of paper I'm gonna put it my
locker because I wanted as motivation
yeah so here's a guy who's first-ballot
Hall of Fame but here he is saying to
himself you know JJ Watt did the same
thing these guys like can I keep this
I'm like yeah go ahead keep it whatever
they're saying what have you seen draft
profiles on you of what they say you
know I've seen a couple of things
but not not extensively any so any
negatives that they've said about you
that stand out you know the whole thing
my old career has been my arm strength
so I'm sure that's that's one of them
without having looked at it yeah but I
wonder about that that if I said the one
thing you have to have is a quarterback
what's the one thing you every
quarterback has or greatness that you
have that so it's not so you want to
have timing and accuracy that's but the
timing and accuracy comes from
understanding the the offense and the
defense so it all starts with the brain
you got to be smart but then you got to
be accurate and be able to throw on time
as well so you got to understand the ins
and outs of the offense so you can use
your eyes to manipulate the defense then
you have to understand what the defense
is doing so you can do that as well and
open up when windows wider than what
they usually are to to throw on time and
then you got to throw accurately how
many times you go to the line of
scrimmage this year and say this is
gonna be a touchdown not I threw 60 so
probably thirty how do you hide it when
you know you got the look away from the
guy I'm gonna throw to the best I can
but you know when you see coverage and
know what you've called and it's just a
matter of you if you put the ball in the
right place as long as you know certain
plays or just me making plays or our
receivers making place but a lot of them
are our schemed up plays against a
certain coverage and when I see that
coverage I'm I'm pretty excited as long
as we as long as the whole line holds up
for two seconds then we'll get it we'll
throw it any trench talk in the national
title game no not to me too much
what do they say when somebody does
trench don't you you know there's a lot
at the beginning of the year and I never
start the trash talk but I think you can
see I usually finish it you know they
the Auburn game it felt like there was a
little there's a little knob and game
yeah but usually about the third quarter
people stop talking trash to me well
then there was that the interception and
and you got hit and then that defensive
lineman standing over you UCF yeah oh
okay I was 28
yeah I'd had to hurt it didn't hurt as
much I just knocked the wind out of me
so I couldn't breathe I was pretty
disappointed in myself that I didn't pop
right back up yeah usually when I get
hit I pop right back up but that one I
just couldn't breathe try to stay down
for a second
do you understand what Coach Cho was
saying all the time most of the time
once he gets going I try to pick out
every like third or fourth work yeah
when my first year there was difficult
during the games cuz he gets fired up
and starts you know revert back to his
southern Louisiana Cajun accent just nod
your head yeah what have you heard from
the bengals nothing really it sorry you
know I haven't talked to any teams yet
you know where you can't really talk to
him and tell the combine too much yeah
do you want to do you want to hear from
the bengals of whenever you're in the
conversation for the number one pick
it's obviously a dream come true but
they I know they have a process to go
through I have a process to go through
so that's it's a long ways away but it
is being number one or going to the
right team the most important to you
combination of both you know you want to
go number one but you also want to go to
a great organization that's committed to
winning committed to winning Super Bowls
because it feels like that you know
people can't believe that you'd want to
go play for the Bengals like why would
you and I said well do you want to pull
a knee lie and say that I don't want to
play there and then they go well you're
from Ohio I go well that doesn't mean
that you're a Bengals fan yeah this is a
business decision yeah I mean so you
know there's a lot of factors that go
into it and my dream always has been to
play in the NFL and that's I mean the
fact that I'm sitting on here being in
the conversation of the number one pick
is honestly crazy to me watching the
draft growing up watching the guys walk
out and hold their Jersey so you know
there's there's a lot of things that go
into it but it's a huge honor
dolphins got a couple of number-one
picks here now I heard something about
that yeah
how do you look in dolphin colors there
I don't know I've never worn TV like
that before it well how do you have you
look you got the tiger stripes already
out with Li Shu now the Bengals there I
think I can pull off just about any
color oh I like that what do you drink
in there by the way yeah we got a little
Bowl 24 it's a new gatorade product that
you know Gator everyone knows what
Gatorade is you drink it on the field to
stay hydrated but this bowl 24 is is the
off the field drink it's got
antioxidants electrolytes all that good
stuff
and I'm super excited to be partnering
with them it's an elite brand you glad
the Bengal questions are over yeah let
me let me break that up there so you're
not talking about the Bengals favorite
football player growing up
besides Brees how did you become a
Reggie Bush fan I mean did you watch him
in college yeah but I didn't mean he was
my favorite player that meant he was my
favorite player oh you were USC fan no I
was a Reggie Bush fan I mean I was in
Nebraska fan growing up because you know
my dad and both my brothers played there
and so I was a die-hard Nebraska fan did
they recruit you they did not
oh no yeah that one that hurt that hurt
real bad yeah that's where I wanted to
go so wait your brothers and your dad
and your your dad doesn't have any pole
there to say or your brothers to say not
we thought we did we thought we did
wow that's got to be that's got to hurt
yeah yeah did your brother's make fun of
you that you didn't get you know
brothers can be no they just weren't
very happy with the program okay yeah
yeah they weren't very happy yeah well I
think he did all right there yeah I
think I did all right
Congrats did you keep any souvenirs from
this year yeah I got a hide with with
all the confetti in it from after the
game you know like they have in the Hall
of Fame cases they just put the Hat
there and all the confetti is in there
so I got that in my apartment
the dance you had after you won did you
see that video yeah I saw them okay what
exactly is that dance that
yeah okay because I didn't know if you
know how to dance and I danced a little
bit no I was that that you were actually
doing the dance correctly yeah it's not
really a dance though Joe I guess not
you know it's a move it was kind of the
the theme song of our championship run
it kind of started in the SEC
Championship best athlete on your team
was who clyde Edwards ealer no question
no question really unreal he'll he's
gonna play for 20 years
really yeah but he was spectacular you
know he had some moves where he mean
everyone looks at all my stats because
we threw the ball so much because we had
great guys on the outside as well but I
mean Clyde is Clyde's a different beast
don't you have a defensive back who
could play wide receiver as well I think
we got a couple of them you know got
grant Christian and and Stingley and and
sting Lee's I mean he's he's the best
young player that I've ever seen I just
think that if I'm LSU I'd have him play
offense next year as well cuz he Mart
might already be the best defensive back
in the nation yeah he might as well move
on to something else challenge but that
had to help you in practice going
against these guys so when he so Derek
came as a true freshman and did some you
know where they had the early signing
day now so they can come for Bowl
practice so 2018 he was doing the ball
practice with us and I was throwing his
I was throwing his way every single time
just to see if you know he lived up to
all the hype and yeah he did good luck
with this whole process there's you know
yeah and it'll go by quickly try to have
fun with it
Boult 24 by Gatorade Bowl 24 off the
field hydrator to learn more about this
drink bowl 24 calm jobber oh we're back
after this on the Dan Patrick
for more Dan Patrick show tune in to
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]